please don't think German how is your  sleep not good I've been walking in my  sleep and I have nightmares usually  there's a man I can't see him but I know  he wants to hurt me and I can't get away  do the same dreams repeat well it's  always the same man  you'd like to do is have you stay here  for a few nights so we can build a  profile of your sleep life we will know  when you're dreaming it will also have  someone watching you throughout the  night so I can't leave Portia's yeah but  only when you're awake  excuse me I'm sorry it's Sara you don't  remember how do you feel and this other  world recognizes me then feels like the  man in my dreams he wants to hurt me  what happened to your husband  yeah Oh God he was obsessed with my  husband's books this doesn't make sense  to me  [Applause]  I love Jonathan gray but I wasn't his  wife I was the other woman  I'm burning  [Music]  you